[Music]
that takes almost two years there and I in the
morning show was good in his note that
we paid this week
[Music]
avoid
[Applause]
cronyism had me at once and in
my party it is said all kinds 66 ugh
friends family for my people dreams
so often vital art
makes like tents and you who dance
the image is hammering Miguel Marín
is already with so many people on top of the
species ruling and thousands are going to vote
[Music]
so they will live
and if it is for me of families we go to
ships and cheer and you are tinte all
kinds
66 a path for me my family are
previously mentioned that there are 66 families for
my friends
in my life
for me for my dream on my face
no more
or no
[Music]
I am happy
yes no
for me
and nothing
for my family my mom
with my friends also
for me nothing
[Music]
well
ah
[Music]